aujourd'hui c'est parce que tu dis il
faut parler sérieusement cette
proposition ou tu sais comment tu es de
gauche
le succès était quand même disons pas
extraordinaire sens pas sans faire de la
lône est moins alarmant moi je crois et
parce que je crois qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une évolution dans notre société dans
qu'est ce que ça veut dire être de
beauce
droite et que c'est vrai que l'écologie
par exemple est quelque chose qui est
transversal et qu' on ne peut pas
simplement dire langlois d'accord mais
je sais qu'on n'est pas d'accord et moi
l'écologie ne peut pas n'est pas
compatible avec le capitaine mais la
question mais ce que je veux dire ça
aussi l'agression on nous l'a fait il ya
25 ans avec le mouvement des femmes
l'émancipation des femmes n'est pas
compatible avec le capitalisme
si les femmes avaient attendu la fin
avec est encore immense ip maintenant je
me suis dit moi je n'ai jamais dit ça
non mais tu l'as dit à l'instant moi je
veux dire je n'ai jamais dit à propos du
féminisme avait là la logique d'une dans
l'en but au commencement une fin une
discussion non sans faire des sauts de
cabri de tous les côtés si moi je
cherche la pays que le ch et un carnet
qui a fait 15% et le sucre et moi je
suis pas française là je suis une vasque
quelques pips reconnaît pas la chose qui
est aujourd'hui j'ai regardé les mêmes
troupes de l'identique oui absolument